tony you're going to like this one right
now because uh we are men of a certain
age my talk of the table is a new sleep
study it shows which age group gets the
least amount of shut-eye okay so check
this out researchers at medical college
of georgia say 40-year-old americans
that's right that's right tony they
suffer from the greatest lack of sleep
they say the amount of sleep tends to uh
go back up in your 50s so tony we got
about a decade or so um and the
three-year study used a device that
detects movement for you to figure out
how long these participants were
actually sleeping now it turns out women
get more sleep throughout their lives
than men do a whole
four minutes worth oh that's nice do you
guys think that's true that you get less
sleep yeah at this point for sure yeah
in fact don't you think it's because of
this shift
no i think it's
okay there's every you know when you're
in your 40s you sometimes have elderly
parents and young children that's just a
job and all three of those things
combined just it just generates
restlessness yeah for that's for sure
yeah but it's okay though all right it's
okay it's okay we've got 10 years why
don't you go back up